انقلابات عسكريه ويحكمها بالبرود والنار
يقول تحلم ولاجل الشفافيه وضمان المستقيه
اجدد اعلانى صراحه تعهدي والتزامي لعدم
الترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله
[موسيقى]
ليبيا امام مفترق طرق مصيريه بعد 12 عاما
من الازمات المتلاحقه ثلاثه مسارات تحدد
مستقبل البلاد السياسي
اتفاق تاريخي حل قد ياتي من الضغوط
الداخليه والدوليه على رئيس مجلس النواب
في الشرق ورئيس الحكومه المعترف بها دوليا
في طرابلس بعد اخفاق الاطراف كافه في
اجراء الانتخابات وتلويح الامم المتحده
والدول الغربيه بايجاد اليات بديله
هنود الاتفاق المحتمل ستنص على تقاسم
وزاره سياديه مثل الخارجيه والدفاع
والداخليه والماليه وبذلك يحصل الجنرال
المتقاعد خليفه حفتر على شرعيه سياسيه في
الداخل كله مقابل اعترافه بحكومه الدبابه
في طرابلس
انتخابات وحكومه تكنوقراط يرى محللون ان
المفاوضات بين مجلس النواب والمجلس الاعلى
للدوله قد تفضي الى تاليف حكومه تكنوقراط
مصغره تتولى اجراء الانتخابات في موعد
جديد خلال عام لكن حكومه طرابلس ترفض
تسليم السلطه الا لحكومه منتخبه ويصطدم
هذا الخيار بالاضطرابات السياسيه بين مجلس
الدوله والنواب بعد منح الاخير الثقه
لحكومه باشاجا ثم سحبها منه
ترسيخ الانقسام
السيناريو الاقرب للحدوث وفق مراقبين ففي
ظل غياب اي تفاهمات محتمله بين دبيبه
وحفتر قد يلجا البرلمان في الشرق الى
تعيين رئيس حكومه جديد بالتوازي مع حكومه
طرابلس المعترف بها دوليا وهذا ما سيبعد
البلاد اكثر عن الانتخابات والحل النهائي
[موسيقى]